[Musique]
mardi 7 mars c'était le sixième rang de
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites une journée de mobilisation
massive dans les transports et les
écoles sur 108 écoles du 1er degré des
Yvelines qui ont répondu à l'enquête du
SNU IPP FSU 78 21 fermés selon
l'académie de Versailles un peu plus de
38% des collèges étaient grévistes
presque 24% des lycées et presque 31%
des écoles du premier degré le secteur
de l'énergie est également touché en
tout début de matinée la CGT a annoncé
le blocage d'expédition du carburant
dans toutes les raffineries plusieurs
bus sont partis des Yvelines pour se
rendre au cortège à Paris à 14h une
soixantaine de cheminots ont d'ailleurs
manifesté ce mardi dans les rues de
Versailles à l'occasion de la 18e
édition de la Semaine nationale du Rhin
organisée par francein plusieurs
dépistages anonymes et gratuits sont
organisés dans les Yvelines le Centre
Hospitalier Intercommunal de Poissy
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en propose le
jeudi 9 mars le centre hémodialyse du
Mantois à Mantes-la-Jolie le vendredi 10
mars et le Centre Municipal de Santé de
Sartrouville le jeudi 16 mars en France
une personne sur dix est concernée par
la maladie rénale si vous souhaitez
reprendre une activité professionnelle
et que les métiers du numérique vous
attirent 50 ans en Yvelines vous propose
d'intégrer gratuitement un string camp
du 16 au 24 mars au programme 10 jours
pour s'initier au métier du numérique
des inscriptions sont ouvertes sur le
site de l'agglomération avis aux fans de
rap qui rêvent d'apprendre à manier les
mots l'artiste de la scène rap Tracy de
ça viendra partager ses techniques le
mercredi 29 mars à 15h au nouvel espace
jeune du valibout à Plaisir organisé par
la clé des champs la rencontre est
gratuite mais le nombre de places est
limité les inscriptions se font sur
place les mercredis 8 et 15 mars de 14
heures à 18h
si vous avez entre 16 et 25 ans et que
vous résidez à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
vous pouvez désormais participer au Défi
Jeunes si vous avez un projet personnel
lié à la citoyenneté l'environnement le
sport ou encore la culture vous avez
jusqu'au 26 mars pour le proposer et
déposer votre candidature à la ville
vous pouvez gagner une bourse de
financement jusqu'à 1000 euros
[Musique]